this Talk's called The Ten Commandments
of reliable data science
will kind of chew through all the pieces
of that and what they mean but uh just
to pick one Ten Commandments that's
tongue-in-cheek
um I think the reason that we all go to
conferences like this and we talk about
things like this is because everyone's
interested in craftsmanship so these
really aren't Commandments they're
guidelines but in the real world we'd
have a beer and argue about which ones
of these are wrong and and things like
that after the talk
um but we can do that in Discord after
this and I look forward to to talking
about it
so let's Jump Right In uh this picture
is from a famous airline disaster where
two experienced respected Pilots with
well-trained Crews collided and a lot of
passengers lost their lives and it
launched a whole field of accident
analysis which sort of inspires this
talk and it's about Norms culture and
quality improvement that ended up going
from this sort of thing to making air
safety one of the safest and I kind of
had a whole story uh prepared to
motivate why we would even need this
this talk at all
um but an interesting thing happened a
couple days ago which is that there was
a sort of viral blog post about data
science a critical blog post that made
the rounds and uh I think sort of proves
the point so if you want to hear about a
a bad data science project gone wrong at
a big company
um you can read the long version of this
which I'll link to at the end but
um let's let's talk about the discussion
that's been going on the last few days
this is a post called goodbye data
science about a practitioner who's
moving on from the field to data
engineering and had some uh some you
know critical things to say about the
way we do things and there were a lot of
responses to this uh that were just
um
sympathizing echoing saying things are
even worse than this person was saying
and it was really eye-opening to see not
just how data scientists think about
their own field but how data Sciences
sometimes perceived in other parts of
the organization so some of the things
people were saying were that analyzes
are often wrong
um and couldn't possibly be right
because they were flawed from the
beginning or leaked data there are
things that are incorrect that should
have been foreseen or people think that
data scientists take forever and produce
work that's not valuable anyway and so
we we need to take these things
seriously even if we're not necessarily
having any of these problems right now
on our team it seems like there's
there's something that bears more
scrutiny in our field
and I want to just make the point that
even if you don't have correctness
issues in your projects or that sort of
data science problem that we'll talk
about today doesn't happen on your team
um the reason that I think sometimes
people judge data science poorly is that
from the outside it looks sometimes
pretty mysterious and artisanal and the
thing about engineering disciplines is
they try very hard not to be artisanal
if you need to rely on heroics and you
need to rely on everyone being
unbelievably perfect then it's not
engineering it's it's some it's some
kind of art form and so for data science
to be reliable we need to get Beyond
this Alchemy perception
so the way we come at this our argument
on my team has a few basic ideas one is
that data science work is a kind of
software and so we know from the field
of software and they're grappling with
this for the last 50 years that
correctness and reliability of software
depends in large part on the development
practices of the people that make it so
data science quality depends on software
engineering quality
and today we're not really talking about
code running in production we're not
really talking about ml Ops or devops or
you know randomized controlled trials
we're talking about the modal data
science project where a data scientist
gets asked to look into something and
typically and I know there are products
that try to address some of these things
but typically the data scientists will
open up a notebook either on their
computer or a server and start working
on the problem so we're talking about
that
and and then where is this coming from
um some of the thoughts here come from
Consulting data science Consulting
working with lots and lots of different
organizations on lots and lots of
projects and seeing how other teams do
things and also running competitions
where we get to see how people that are
amazing at the the computational part
how do they organize code what do
projects look like in the wild
so let's dive right into the rules the
first one is maybe one of the most
common uh commonly experienced and and
that's the projects are disorganized so
we need to start a project in an
organized way and find a way to keep it
organized
um we all know this pain this you see a
file
it has some weird name it's sitting
right next to a bunch of other files
that we don't know where they came from
and what order they should be running
lots of data science projects are like
this it's just a fact
um and I think a lot of this it doesn't
come from bad intentions but it comes
from an idea that will start you know
just playing jazz and then we'll clean
it up later and unfortunately that that
somehow never really happens
I mean there are a lot of papers and
ideas about how to organize projects and
all of them are basically good if if
teams follow any guidelines at all
almost that's that's uh you know an 80
solution
but we really take inspiration from the
kind of Django model here and if I start
a Django project everything's always
organized about the same way and so even
if I'm coming to somebody's project that
I've never seen before I kind of know
where the database models are going to
be they're in models.pi I know where the
URLs are going to be they're in urls.pi
and the nice thing about that is that
enables us to collaborate it's less
artisanal my project isn't some weird
one-off thing I only ever did once
um if I structure it in a repeatable way
other people
should be able to figure that out so we
have a project that does this called
cookie cutter data science which is
fairly popular
um out in the field but it almost
doesn't matter what template or project
gets used and there are there are a
number to choose from if the team is
using one
the projects tend to stay much more
organized
and you know a lot of times it's it's
often no more than just a good file and
folder layout and sometimes that's
enough but teams can get really
sophisticated about the way they do this
doing something is more important
another idea that we won't spend too
much time on is that everything comes
from somewhere and the raw data is
immutable and this is already generally
fairly accepted that you don't mess
around with like the data extract or the
the original Source data but this idea
of a directed acyclic graph we we talk
about often in data science
but
um when it comes time for people to
actually make sure that their projects
obey this idea it's a little bit less
common for it to be well obeyed and this
this kind of thing is something that we
see a lot out there where there's a file
in the project that's critical to
something
but I'm looking at it and I don't know
where it came from and I don't know how
reliable it is and where do we get a new
copy when this one gets out of date how
do I know if it's out of date and so on
and so forth and this is just endemic I
mean it's really it's kind of hard to
find a project where you just open it up
the first time and things smooth
smoothly flow from end to end
we'll talk a little bit more about tools
for that in a minute but we can't even
get to those tools before we talk about
Version Control and at this point this
wasn't really true 10 years ago
necessarily but at this point most teams
are using git or something like it
um so the rule isn't really about using
it at all it's about how do we use it
for the things specific to data science
a couple notes there
we think the data mostly should not be
kept in Source control and often people
don't do this just because they can't if
you try to add a really large file your
git will have problems but one of the
problems with adding any files to Source
control even kind of smaller
intermediate ones is that reproducible
pipelines that don't get exercise tend
to be broken
this is true where in in devops people
kind of understand culturally that if
you don't test your data backup system
it just won't work and that's like a
norm that people have
and there are a lot of ways and places
to store files but as long as teams
adopt some practice that's standard
across projects it's it's usually okay
um there are more
complicated tools but often uh just
having a way to capture where data gets
stored at all is is more important
the other things that Version Control
Systems enable code review and we'll
talk more about this later but now that
a lot of teams are using uh GitHub or
gitlab or atlassian products when you're
using Version Control we use code review
but in data science sadly a lot of times
we don't do as much code review
sometimes that's because it's a little
bit harder to review the work
sometimes it's just because the files
are harder like a notebook is a Json
file and yes tools exist but do people
use them if you go out and you look
around people don't really use tools for
those
so we have this project called NB Auto
export which mirrors a DOT Pi file
anytime you save your notebook but
really more important than what tool you
use is just finding a way for the team
to review each other's code so that
there isn't a norm of just download The
Notebook and Eyeball it
the next rule is maybe one of the most
important which is that notebooks are
really for exploration
but source files are for repetition and
automation
so notebooks we all know what the
benefits are most of us use them all the
time you can iterate rapidly test out a
lot of different things interleave code
and explanation
they're very visual that's an excellent
property good for communication but
mostly teams don't use tools for running
them in an automated way which mostly
means that for running them it's a
person opening up a notebook and doing
the things they're difficult for Version
Control we just talked about that a
little but they encourage repetition
which is another Insidious issue which
is that if everything's in notebooks you
can't it's hard to import from another
notebook so people copy things around
and errors creep in that way we see that
all the time
I know someone's going to say Netflix
runs notebooks in production it's a
really cool idea um and they seem to do
it quite well the thing to remember is
most Netflix has teams of people that
maintain this tool and make sure it's
running and they have operation centers
and most of us do not
so the typical workflow is to have
gigantic notebooks that do everything
from loading to cleaning uh
Transformations model training model
outputs and visualizations and the
problem with this is it involves an
awful lot of eyeballing and people get
squirrely about moving up and changing
some things and not re-running all the
things because some are slow and all of
that stuff and so when we do it this way
we add a lot of places that error can
creep in
um so a more balanced workflow is to use
notebook for what it's great at which is
getting rapid feedback but and and
looking at things so when you get a
piece working if it's not the piece
you're trying to look at if it's utility
code or some
uh computational function you need but
it's not really the point of the
analysis it makes sense to move it to a
source file a place that can be linted
version controlled code reviewed more
easily and tested which we'll talk about
more
so rule five tests and Sanity checks
prevent catastrophes and they are highly
highly underused in the field
and that's that's understandable because
of all code out there data science code
is pretty hard to test
um sometimes it involves big data sets
sometimes uh data changes so your values
change so it's hard what are you
asserting if the value changes we use
Randomness on purpose and so things
change and you know tests usually assume
you're testing something reaches an
expected value visualizations are are
really hard to test and notebooks just
don't have the same amount of tooling
for running and Discovery tests
but that doesn't mean that we can't do
it especially if we're obeying the last
rule which is to move you know often
used or common functions out to source
files now we can write tests so here's
an example of like a have or sign
function so so distance on a sphere and
just some just some tests of edge cases
nothing crazy but what happens if it's
zeros what happens if you know some
value is missing
and that's the kind of thing that isn't
too big a lift and we could be doing but
most teams are not
on that note the idea of testing what
things work and what things don't
in data science code we generally want
to fail loudly and quickly when anything
is off instead of trying to handle
exceptions which is uh a big part of
thinking about software engineering
and the reason for this is not because
data science code is so fragile the
reason is because a lot of data science
code is actually pretty robust to things
happening in a way that's not desirable
so this cartoon the reason it's funny is
because in a lot of our workflows when
we get the shape of the data right and
all the things run if everything kind of
multiplies out and there are no crucial
logic errors you'll get numbers you you
can you can force the force the machine
to give you numbers but are they right
you know that's that's harder to insure
so and and this is just a known property
of systems that use any kind of
probabilistic modeling which is uh the
whole reason they're useful is they deal
with noise well and so uh if noise is
coming in but we don't know what's
coming in that's a problem
and you can see this even in the very
simplest case you imagine that some part
of our analysis involves like a mean of
some values imagine there are a lot more
of these and they're coming from someone
else
we take the mean we get a number great
this is good
but what if some of them start to be
missing what if they're missing in a
non-random way that affects the
conclusions of the analysis the truth is
that a lot of our tools
will handle this gracefully if not
correctly or if not in the way that we
intent and so when I get this number out
it looks just like the number I got a
second ago but this has different
properties and this can be catastrophic
so one way of thinking about this is to
test all of the assumptions that we're
implicitly or explicitly bringing to our
functions
and this is called assertion testing and
it's underused I think but part of that
is because in normal software
engineering assertions are viewed
especially in production code as like a
a red flag meaning that this is
something for testing and it shouldn't
be here whereas in data science code
there are different set of assumptions
it's a different kind of code
so actually these types of assertions uh
can be Lifesavers it means that yeah
your code will fail but if it fails that
means someone's going to look at it
hopefully and try to understand why it
failed so we don't want to work if we
shouldn't be working and that's why
adding lots of assertions liberally to a
code base especially if it's hard to
test in unit tests or integration tests
just adding assertions that capture what
we think should be happening can help a
lot
there are packages that try to do this
in a more
um you know pythonic way some more
maintained than others but basically
just the idea of defensive programming
is something that I think we all can
integrate into our workflows
another is that project runs should be
fully automated from the raw data to the
final outputs
and this is kind of an interesting rule
because it's hard to find people that
disagree with this
people generally think that this is true
but on the other hand it's hard to find
data science projects
you know real world projects not well
polished sort of Open Source libraries
and things like that but real projects
where it lives up to this aspiration
um
a lot of times there are steps hopefully
documented but often not that need to
happen and so you can't actually recover
outputs even if you have every other
part of the project
people have thought a lot about this
going back to that idea of accident
analysis uh Dr Atul gawand in his book
The checklist Manifesto was all about
how uh how human systems fail and
even if you've written down all the
steps to this analysis or whatever even
if you know how to do it and you're the
only one doing it
um the point is that people get lulled
into a false sense of security and steps
get skipped and people say things like
this has never been a problem before
until at some point it's a problem
going back to the idea of the the dag
representing our work as a graph
um there are a lot of tools that do this
that turn that idea into something that
can be run and everyone kind of knows
about these but they're they're
underused if you if you see as many data
science projects as we do
um people have lots of just steps that
aren't captured
even if they're using the tool A lot of
times they just leave out steps and so
being able to turn that idea of a dag
into a into a command that you can run
um is an important part of ensuring the
work that we do is reproducible and
holding ourselves accountable if you run
it from a fresh environment
you can't reproduce the results you know
that's a it's an indicator that that you
need to add more automation to the
project
so just going back to this idea of a
file where did this come from
what what situation would you rather be
in and this is a realistic situation
because people do this both ways out in
the world
um would you rather have that census
shape file the instructions are written
down in human language in a readme uh
telling you do this then do this then do
this
or would you rather have it even if
you're not a big fan of make would you
rather have it documented in a make file
where this target has a command that can
be run and then if the command fails you
know that it failed
I think that I may not always want to
use make on every project but being able
to do this is an important property of a
project in general and so sometimes you
going back to the idea of fail loudly
and fail quickly the fact that you can
run these means that if you delete
everything that's intermediate and run
it again you see which parts are not
reproducible you can fix it
a lot of tools out there for this they
all have different trade-offs the point
is just using one learning it and making
sure it's a norm on the team that the
Project's not done until all of those
steps are part of that graph and can be
run
important parameters should be extracted
and centralized
this is actually a Norm that's growing
in popularity and I think a lot of the
libraries that people use a lot have
helped set this expectation but just
looking at this
this uh function signature for uh
creating a a gradient boosted regressor
um there's this there's this phenomenon
that that we call the problem of
parameters which is that
um even if you don't fill most of these
in there are options and so in order to
really reproduce someone's analysis you
need to know all of the things that went
into this uh right here at the time it
was called
and in a lot of the projects that we see
in the world even for amazing teams
world-class teams experienced data
scientists A lot of times you can't
fully specify the behavior of the
program without like six layers of
places where these values could live
environment variables make variables
um a central configuration file for the
project uh command line arguments uh
constants that live at the top of files
and then magic numbers or quarks that
are just passed right where they're
called Somewhere in the code
um and what we kind of recommend for
this is uh to extract a lot of those
values out to a central location where
they are very visible and easy to change
and easy to store in Version Control and
then look back later and see everything
all in kind of one place without trying
to do archeology about what the you know
what the environment was at that time
things like that
relatedly we think runs of a project
like runs of a data pipeline
um even one for research we're not
talking about you know code running in
production but research code where
people are doing experiments
runs of the project should be verbose
and result in artifacts what do we mean
um
well looking at the typical workflow
we're working in a notebook we change a
bunch of things we just look at the
output cells with our eyes and then we
decide at some point whether it's good
enough and we're you know kind of
thinking back about the last few hours
and whether this is better or worse and
at a certain point we run out of time or
we decide it's okay and we move on
with all the rules we've been talking
about so far that gets us pretty far so
we're testing uh you know we're using a
an orchestration tool we have our
parameters extracted our life has been
changed because we've tied it up a
little bit and uh we're feeling pretty
good but there's still something to miss
here which is that a critical part of
this workflow involves eyeballing the
results and that is tough because even
if your judgment is perfect other people
will have to pick this project up in the
future if it's valuable it will it will
live for a long time and so that
judgment doesn't transfer well but also
um you know it's hard to be right
especially when there's so much
probabilistic noise and complexity in
these projects uh this is not something
that feels good as a practitioner and it
doesn't build trust in the people who
consume our work products
so just going back to like
you know the oldest days of computing
a log file is a powerful thing and this
is what we mean by verbose which is just
logging a lot of stuff and uh resulting
in tangible artifacts like storing this
log somewhere so that you can look at it
later keeping it in Version Control
and this is just a toy example it's but
I want to pick out a couple things here
first is we're putting important bits of
information all in one place could I
look up the what git hash we were on at
a certain point in time yes but if I'm
trying to understand a whole analysis we
want to put everything in one place uh
we can say what the random seed was we
can put the settings in here again
redundancy just to make sure it's easy
to understand
what rows were dropped which ones were
kept and then when we get these things
that just are ephemeral like the when
you do a grid search over the best model
parameters at some point they're in
memory but often they don't get saved
um why don't we just save them you know
create a place for the artifacts from a
run to live
and
um that goes for the results as well and
the you know if we capture the metrics
we don't want to be thinking oh did this
did what I just do in the cell improve
things or not we want to look at the
facts go look at the last run and see
did Precision get better but recall
always worse we want to have that put
somewhere
and then write out the predictions
so maybe it looks like this you can even
copy the files around it's not worth
trying to save 4 KB if this is an
important analysis copy the config file
so you don't have to go on a git
archeology Expedition and keep the log
file right next to the predictions that
came out
which things get stored in Version
Control it's up to you as long as there
are norms on the team almost any
anything sensible will work and I know
people are going to say oh well this is
why uh you know their artifact stores
and and feature versioning and all this
stuff yes
that's true and a lot of teams should be
considering those tools but in practice
when people are just doing kind of
exploratory work
those tools are not often in use
um and this this is a sort of
Middle Ground where people can use the
tools they're familiar with everyone's
familiar with files logs you know you
know settings that are in uh a machine
readable format and so that's a way that
we can get a lot of the benefits without
you know convincing the IT department to
buy a certain Cloud product or something
and then finally this one is great not
just for reliability but also for the
experience of doing work and feeling
good about it
um
is starting with the simplest possible
end-to-end pipeline going all the way
from raw data to whatever it is we're
trying to deliver at the end and getting
it even if none of the individual parts
are satisfactory yet getting it in the
form such that it it produces
something that we can almost deliver so
that then we can make educated decisions
about where to spend our time rather
than worrying about whether we'll ever
finish this project
so imagine a project where we try to
take raw data and visualize it we sort
of tend to work backwards and then think
forward so we need to get all the data
clean it all up
um you know train a bunch of models
Ensemble them and then build an app
but this is this is waterfall this is a
dangerous game because if any of these
things get off track then you may never
finish
and so there's this philosophy that we
want to get to the end product before
it's good and get feedback and that we
Implement things when we need them and
not when we think we'll need them so
maybe we just use a little bit of data
some columns a simple model just take
the predictions and oh look we have a
performance this is a benchmark we can
try to improve and we start not with a
visualization but just just printing in
a table
so it looks terrible but something
happened here which means we split this
up into different concerns that can be
collaborated on at the same time as long
as we understand what format the data is
in
now we can go back and change individual
pieces and see our accuracy improve and
change over time and then decide as a
team what parts to work on and what
parts to leave hello
um we're almost done
if you would like to leave any sometime
for the questions yeah
great so this is the data science
process that that's the ideal case we
can move around we can you know play
jazz a little bit but still feel
confident and the reason that this is
related to reliability and not just
experience is that the faster we can get
feedback and get things in final form
the more likely we are to discover
defects before it's too late
so I invite questions comments angry uh
Pitchfork crowds there's a long version
of this that's on the site
um the link is here and and I'll put the
slides in Discord
um and I'd be happy to take questions we
only have a little time now but in
Discord as well thank you
thank you very much for this very
informative talk and um I've learned a
bunch thank you
thank you
yeah so Matt asks uh thoughts on nbw
these I I I've looked into it and it
looks great to me
um there are a lot of projects to try to
do this kind of thing they each make
different trade-offs I'm in favor of
projects like that but it's my
observation that most teams are not
using them and you know running cookie
cutter data science we often have people
come in and say Here's my pull request
everyone should be using dat
maybe they should but the fact is that
they're not so if we try to impose this
from the outside and say everyone should
use this it's not not a successful way
to build cultural norms
good good question
um the thing to realize is a lot of
these are aspirational right so I say
these things with a straight face
my team I personally don't always live
up to these things they're they're
things to think about so I think
if you if you come to a team and you say
you know you guys are all messed up uh
we need to be adopting these practices
right now we're doing Alchemy and not
engineering because this random person
said so you know that's less successful
in saying what are the painful things
everyone knows the pain of census
shapefile V2 new use this for real final
dot xlsx whatever so starting with the
pain points and trying to persuade with
you know a vision of what things could
be like is is more useful